mais c'est le match attendu de ce week
end la rencontre psg om au stade de
france 2 mme à des mesures de sécurité
hors normes ont été mises en place pour
accueillir et canaliser les supporteurs
des deux camps qui ne se sont jamais
rencontrés en finale de la coupe de
france franck guinaudeau sophie rodier
nadine picard à quelques heures du
départ c'est l'effervescence à marseille
les supporters règle les derniers
détails du grand voyage
objectif ramener la coupe de france
qu'elle a bien nous attend et on fait
l'aller-retour va chercher convoler avec
rick l
3 serra on va leur faire plaisir comme
moi pas dire 6 à 0
du côté du parc des princes c'est un
calme olympien qui régnait cet après
midi les supporters en profite pour
faire les derniers achats
ici aussi c'est l'optimisme qui prévaut
contre marseille peuvent tout perdre
c'est pas possible ils vont fallu faire
ça à un but de ribéry pour marseille et
de witte de pauleta pour calmer tout le
monde et montrer quel patron om psg
c'est l'histoire d'une rivalité qui a
souvent déraper saccage des bus de la
ratp par des marseillais attaque du bus
de l'om par des parisiens
les rivaux historiques se sont souvent
retrouvés à la rubrique faits divers
sans compter les bagarres entre
supporteurs parisiens qui ont émaillé la
saison
pour prévenir de nouveaux débordements
deux mille trois cent policiers seront
présents sur le terrain et pour éviter
de se croiser à chacun son moyen de
transport ligne 13 rer d pour marseille
rer b pour park dans le stade
chacun son virage sud pour paris nord
pour marseille
et en cas d'incident ce sera tolérance
zéro occurrence de la république sera
d'ailleurs présent sur le site avec ses
magistrales de façon à
diddy j'ai immédiatement des procédures
pour les persuader qu'ils auront donc
été interpellé dans ce cas de figure
tout est prévu il existe même des
cellules de garde à vue à l'intérieur du
stade
enfin comme depuis plusieurs semaines
certains supporters parisiens jugés à
risque devront pointer au commissariat à
l'heure du coup d'envoi
juste pour vous signaler que monsieur
signé chez eux ne pourront pas assister
au match de l'année